so we seem to have arrived at the moment
of truth for our entrepreneurs they've
got to pick a model to implement Germany
suggestion 0 sure in many cases the
choice is pretty clear for example most
games are using a freemium model and SAS
generally using subscriptions both
benefits from the trust they created
with their users however there is no
replacement to keep trying and tuning
the models that fit your special needs
there are cases where you have enough
funding and you wish to focus on growth
it's totally fine since the value of
your company is composed from the
current revenue stream and the future
one let's also hear from some other
startups to get their advice on choosing
a monetization strategy